Justice League we hardly knew ye
filmmaker writer and comic book superfan
Kevin Smith recently revealed on his fat
man beyond podcast that Zack Snyder's
2017 film was meant to be the first in a
trilogy he also offered up a bunch of
juicy details on the movies that might
have been according to Smith his inside
knowledge is the result of a visit he
paid to the set of the upcoming Star
Wars Episode nine during that visit he
had a chance to chat with a number of
unnamed crew members who worked on as he
put it both versions of Justice League
that refers to both Justice League as it
was originally conceived under Snyder as
well as the reshot and reworked final
version overseen by the Avengers
director Joss Whedon they called the
Justice League when Snyder was doing it
Zack Snyder when Joss Whedon came in and
take over they called it Justice League
Whedon took over the production of
Justice League when Snyder was forced to
depart due to a family tragedy but
apparently Whedon did much more than
just finish the movie as many fans have
long suspected he also oversaw a
dramatic overhauling of what the movie
was about and what it was building to
Smith asserted on the January 29th
episode of his podcast that Snyder's
version of Justice League was originally
meant to build toward not just one but
rather two sequels according to Smith
the first movie was meant to proceed
much like the finished version audiences
saw in 2017 following the newly formed
league as they met and fought the new
gods step in a wall however the ending
of the movie is originally conceived
would have revealed the encounter to be
just a prelude to the real fight to come
Smith asserted that Justice League was
originally supposed to end with a
sequence revealing the ultimate villain
to not be Steppenwolf but rather
Darkseid the heroes would encounter the
infamous DC villain viewing the film's
events through a boom to a sort of extra
dimensional tunnel which can be opened
with the aid of a mother box boom tube
opened up and they saw dark side and
dark sides saw them boom tube closes
that's the end of the movie this would
have led directly into a sequel in which
the Justice League would have become
aware of the growing threat posed by
Darkseid and his alien minions according
to Smith the movie would have sent the
Justice League into outer space taking
the fight directly to the intergalactic
despot it's home planet of Epoque
the second film would have brought in
several of DC Comics more cosmic
elements including the Green Lantern
Corps with some version of Green Lantern
himself joining the fight apparently the
scene from a Justice League comic-con
trailer which featured Jeremy Irons is
Alfred addressing an unknown person was
meant to feature the Dark Knight's
Butler interacting with Green Lantern
the scene and the Green Lantern was cut
from the film when Whedon took over he
said you've come
no that's hope you know too late
Smith acknowledged that many have
assumed the scene was meant to involve a
revived Superman but according to the
filmmakers sources that wasn't always
the case we had green lights that were
flashing on Jeremy Irons to project the
green glow
I said why he goes because it was Green
Lantern according to Smith the proposed
second movie would have ended on a dark
note in the vein of Avengers infinity
war or The Empire Strikes Back with the
heroes of the Justice League separated
stranded and otherwise defeated by
Darkseid and his minions the movie would
have ended with Darkseid arriving on
earth causing mass destruction and
ending the film on a hopeless note the
third movie would have finally shown
audiences the reality of the apocalyptic
vision experienced by Bruce Wayne and
Batman vs Superman strange nightmare
sequence the trilogy would have
ultimately concluded with the Justice
League
reunited returning to earth to make
their final stand against Darkseid in
the armies of apocalypse
ever since the poor critical performance
and muted box office turnout for Batman
vs Superman Warner Brothers has been
pivoting away from Snyder's vision for
the DC movie universe many fans were
left unsatisfied by how Justice League
ended up turning out but Smith's report
suggests there was originally a strong
vision for the project one that was
close to coming to fruition but since
Justice League entered production so
soon after the release of Batman vs
Superman course corrections were made on
the fly dramatically altering the movie
from the form it was supposedly meant to
take we may not ever fully know what
went on during the making of Justice
League but every story that's emerged
from the production suggests the movie
that went through wild changes basically
at the last minute whether Smith's
account of the events is accurate or not
it's only more fuel for the fire for
fans still demanding that WB
least the Schneider cut check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]